okay hello everybody welcome to i/o 2016
people enjoy the keynote yeah all right
a lot of great stuff there and hopefully
will be segwaying into interesting ways
to use some of what you saw we're going
to be using the spaces app to collect
comments and questions so that we can do
that online save a little time so we
don't have to do the QA QA here live so
if you haven't already gotten a update
about that please look it up it should
be connected to your i/o app I believe
and I think there is supposed to be some
signs describing how to use it but let's
just move on I'm Noah falstein I'm chief
game designer here at Google we've got a
lot of great software hardware services
that are really great for game
developers that we're going to be
showing you this year and this is a
great place to start we wanted to have
an orientation early at i/o so that we
can point you to some of the other talks
and also tell you about some of the cool
stuff as well as make some of our own
announcements here so I'm going to be
starting and then I'm going to pass it
on to Ben Frankel here who's lead p.m.
for our Google Play game services and
we're gonna finish up with you know
folks who is with YouTube gaming and
they'll talk to you a little bit about
each of their own specialties but first
I'm just curious how many of you are
here at i/o for the first time ok quite
a few is actually I think this is the
first i/o where we have a majority of
returning people but it looks like we've
got a lot of new faces here and how many
people here are actively involved in the
games industry one way or another ok
pretty much what I expected so a lot of
great stuff for you and before I jump
into some of the new stuff let me put it
into perspective a bit this is actually
a computer game I wrote 40 years ago
this year the codes on the left and the
actual game input and output is on the
right at that point when we were doing
computer games we basically had sort of
glorified electric typewriters and that
was our input and output you in this
particular game we had a list of
numerical commands you would type in
just a year or two after that came out I
saw my first video screen and got to
code
if something that actually controlled
the video on the screen and it was a
revelation for me and of course right
around that time as video and computers
were coming together it made some of the
first video games possible and those
kinds of combinations we've actually
become kind of used to it but every few
years there's some new dramatic mix of
new technologies that can come together
in these great ways you know for example
we had CD ROMs and a higher color
resolution that enabled the kind of
modern graphics that were used to now or
modems and server based architecture
that made MMOs and a lot of the online
games possible and more recently we have
you know smartphones that are putting
those games right in our pocket and
connecting us with everybody else in the
world those are just a few examples the
games industry now is bigger than it's
ever been this is a picture of the GDC
up in San Francisco from Google's
session there this year we had more
people there I think than they even fit
into this room but right in this room
alone we've got almost double the amount
of people that were at the first Game
Developers Conference I went to the
entire conference back thirty years ago
the games industry has grown to
hundredfold since then the sorry the GDC
has grown to hundredfold since then and
with good reason because there are all
these wonderful new technologies
platforms beyond just the kind of
computers and the dedicated consoles
that were used to but of course we've
seen browser-based social gaming and
downloadable games a lot of indie games
coming that way and of course mobile
games of all types and the last couple
of years we've now started to look at
virtual reality and wearables so it's
given us all sorts of wonderful
opportunities and here at Google we make
all sorts of hardware software and
services that help you develop games
grow your audiences enter and some
profits so today as we're talking about
some of those things and in the next few
days as you hear from our other groups I
hope you think about the advantages that
you get when you combine some of those
services together to explore new areas
just as those examples I mentioned in
the past of new things coming together
like that to see what kind of new games
or even new entire types of games that
you can create and the practical reasons
for the experimenting for this there are
a lot of payoffs for you it's really I
think like going
through a secluded mountain pass and
maybe there'll be a dead end on the
other side maybe it'll open up into a
fertile valley maybe there's an entire
new continent of possibility the the
smartphone games when they came out our
whole new continent it's just amazing
how big that's gotten and I think that
we have some really great possibilities
coming up in those areas too one of the
reasons for doing that is if you combine
some new exciting thing like virtual
reality with something as big as the
billion plus Android smartphone users
and make a game that works well in both
of those fields then you've got
something that has the appeal and the
press attention of virtual reality but
the huge market of the existing
smartphones out there and it's not easy
to do that sort of thing but it's
certainly possible and the payoff is
really worthwhile so that's just using
some existing technologies let's
consider some of the new ones that are
being shown in the next few days there's
a lot for you to see in these next few
days so I've made a couple of slides
here and this doesn't include all of the
talks that I think will be of interest
to game developers but I tried to call
some of the ones that I think you'd find
interesting this first page is some of
the upcoming talks about virtual reality
and our project tango devices that are
quite exciting it's not an exhaustive
list and some sessions may move around
to the last minute so please check your
apps and the signs to make sure that
everything's in the right time and place
and there's a lot going on with the game
development and distribution side of
things as well firebase is something you
should look into it's a great way to
leverage the Google advantage that
combines our back-end services
seamlessly in your game and then
tomorrow and Friday there's some more
interesting talks you might want to look
into things like our Android end
discussions or some of the firebase
fundamentals or AdMob and how you could
use that to monetize your games but let
me make a few specific announcements
that you may be hearing about in some
other places as well first I'm really
happy to be able to be making the the
first announcement of the donation API
in the words of the developers
what if gamers everywhere could save the
real world right from within your app
powered by Google
this is the donation API it's made for
gamers and generosity and he uses
everything that we've learned that users
like when they donate it's got in app
donations automatic payment processing
and billing there are no fees and no
spam and it has the ability for you the
developer to search and support any
us-based nonprofit it's brought to you
by the same group the social good group
that is powered donations for google.org
and the refugee crisis and the newly
launched donation cards on YouTube and
I've got some cards describing this that
I'll put out and back later for people
to take as they leave very exciting
stuff I'm really happy to be part of a
company that's thinking not only of
entertaining people but helping them at
the same time next let me suggest that
you check out our app ads for games
making games fun is really essential to
success and so is identifying which
customers are best for your game so take
a look at app ads for games to see how
you can use powerful signals from search
YouTube and the Play Store to find the
best players for your games
and then finally earlier this year we
announced our apps streaming service and
that'll be described on stage 6 later
today this is somewhat different than
the instant apps that were announced at
the keynote they have similar functions
but they're used for different things
and the app streaming people are great
for letting people try out games by
streaming them online without actually
having to download the app onto your
device it works pretty much like videos
are streamed on YouTube and let's player
try your game without having to first
download it which obviously can be a big
advantage to getting them up and running
quickly ok
so let's think about how some of those
advantages can boost your games and
bring them to the next level so here
while you're at i/o you'll be learning
about some of the other tools we have
available to developers and I'm urging
you to really think about how you'd
combine them because as I've been saying
if you bring them together in new ways
it can really help you launch new
creative adventures that draw on a
really diverse palette and increase your
chances to both get noticed and reach
new heights so let me give you a few
thought experiments to show you the
kinds of things I mean to get started
what if you had a game about exploring
the universe
that was played by thousands who are in
a single shower together you'd want to
have complex calculations and that could
be done with Google cloud platform but
the players could view it on their
phones or use our cast services that you
can find out about here to cast it on
through their TVs so that they can
actually see their televisions with a
star scape and pick out their nest next
destination that way or you might have
heard I'm curious how many people have
seen our chrome experiment game light
saber escape okay a fair number of you
great I thought that was a really
exciting way of showing the advantage of
combining what we can do with chrome
with what you can do with your your
phone to control a light saber on the
screen but it uses as most phones to 3
degrees of freedom and orientation
imagine using one of our project tango
devices or one of the new phones that
Lenovo will be making later this year so
that as you're using your lightsaber to
deflect bolts it's not just seeing which
orientation that's in but you can move
it side to side up and down and much
like they do in the movies send those
blaster bolts back at the stormtroopers
I think that might open up a whole new
type of action-adventure game where
you're controlling what you're seeing on
your computer screen with your phone so
that can be a great interface for you
and finally I'll suggest tensorflow
which has been getting a lot of news and
consider how that open source machine
learning tool might be used in
conjunction with something like Google
Earth to create a new kind of game that
fused alternate reality gaming with
massively multiplayer games imagine for
example that you have a world-spanning
game that has procedurally generated
objectives all across Google Earth so
that tensorflow and machine learning can
help learn each player's preferences and
make objectives that are local to where
they are and yet fit into the the kind
of world information that you can pull
in with our services so those are just a
few suggestions as you listen to Ben and
Nina next and as you go out for the next
two and a half days and hear about the
other game talks I'd like you to
consider how you might want to use some
of those services any of the ones that
have been mentioned or new ones that we
may not have even thought of that can be
used by
a MERS that's happening all the time go
out there create some groundbreaking new
games or supercharge your existing games
and speaking of supercharging I'm going
to turn it over now to Ben Frankel PM of
our Google Play game services group to
tell you more about that multi powered
service
thank you Thank You Noah for the intro
hi I'm Ben Frankel I'm a product manager
on the Play Games team and our mission
is to provide developers the tools and
services they need to create great games
and make money while they're doing it
two very important component and we
launched Play game services three years
ago at this event at i/o and we launched
with just the basics we had achievements
we had leaderboards we had a multiplayer
stack we had a cloud save solution and
since then we've become the
fastest-growing game Network ever today
hundreds of millions of users sign into
play game services every month and 50%
of the top 500 games on play are
integrated but since then since the
initial launch and over the years the
needs of developers have substantially
evolved and we've had to evolve along
with them and play game services has
expanded to include advanced features
like video recording live operations and
a healthy dose of predictive analytics
and slide here we go so before I go into
the specific features and case studies
that I want to talk about today I
thought it would be useful to take a
step back and provide some context for
what we're trying to do through the lens
of the game development process so to
start up on the left here I can barely
see things because the awkward angle
here so but starting off on the left a
typical game a typical game will start
off with something like a brainstorming
session I've heard a lot of game
developers have a game jam where people
vote on whatever concept they
think is the best for some maybe it's a
Eureka moment they have in the bathtub
though for me personally I prefer mine
in the shower
and once you've locked in on an amazing
idea it's time to take it one step
further with a prototype and after
you've exhausted your most expedient
testing options like your co-workers
your friends your family maybe a distant
cousin somewhere you need to expand your
audience by launching a beta program or
soft launch in your game and after
iterating awhile and you're confident
your game is awesome it has a chance to
monetize well you're ready to launch and
promote your game to the public hooray
right but these days launching your game
is just the start of the journey for a
game developer you need to continue to
invest in acquiring new users and you
have to retain those users by keeping
your community engaged tailoring and
tuning your content to different player
segments and running live events those
are all very important components but
today I'm going to focus on just three
things that play and play combined with
other Google products are doing to drive
game developer success first we're going
to talk about how we can help you find
the right users at each stage of the
game development process then recover
how we can help you tailor and tune your
game to different player segments and
lastly we'll talk about how we can help
you harness the creativity and
enthusiasm of your gaming community to
deeper and to deepen player engagement
so let's start off with how play can
help you find the right users this is
very important part for everybody's
business so at this year's i/o we're
introducing the early acces section to
the Play Store and as I mentioned
earlier once you've built your initial
prototype and vitter ated a bit it's
important to get feedback from the
largest audience possible before you
launch your game publicly and
that's what the early access section is
for early access will feature exciting
games that are still in development so
that early to dot early adopters and
influencers are able to discover and try
out your game and importantly it also
gives them an opportunity to give you
private feedback this is the perfect way
to experiment and find to your game
before it's finally released to
everybody so when you're finally ready
to launch you'll need to promote your
game and find a way to drive installs
and for those of you who are any
developers you'll be excited to hear
that we've added a new way to highlight
you and your games in the indie corner
collection on the Play Store that we
launched earlier this year at GDC the
indie corner is dedicated to
highlighting truly amazing and unique
games that users love and here's how the
program works so first you have to make
a great game that it all starts there
and then you need to submit your game to
participate in the indie corner program
at this URL that you can see on the
left-hand side of the screen there I
guess you're right sorry
right-hand side and you know it's gqo
ford slash indie corner submission and
from there a panel selects games for
featuring indie or in the indie corner
collection it's simple however there's
more to the indie corner program than
just the featuring though that's
obviously a big benefit it also serves
as a way for us to have the opportunity
to help indie developers understand and
improve their game performance and I'll
walk you through an example of something
we did with a partner of ours spring
loaded so when we started working with
spring loaded they had just launched
soft launch their game last Vikings and
they gave us an early build and we
tested it extensively and we wrote up a
detailed analysis of some things they
could do to improve the game how they
could best integrate play game services
and some tweaks they could make
to improve monetization and retention
then spring-loaded implemented every
single one of our recommendations it was
it was extremely impressive to see it
all come together really nicely and the
results for them have been phenomenal so
after they made a few tweaks here and
there to their game they were able to
double average revenue per paying user
and make huge improvements to retention
they in fact doubled their de7 retention
on the back of the work that we did with
them and in James Bernards own words the
indie corner program has been in
valuable to us in helping us believe
that as a small indie we can actually
make it on our own it has been a
transformative experience for them and
hopefully you'll all be excited here
tomorrow the indie corner collection
will be live on the store so don't
forget to check that out so let's say
you've assumed for a moment that you've
found the right users now you'll want to
keep them coming back to your game by
turning it into an ongoing service you
deliver to players and imports that a
very important piece of that is being
able to dynamically tailor content to
different player segments and in this
case study what we'll cover is how a
developer has combined the player stats
API with admob's
rewarded ads to increase ad revenue
while not negatively impacting in-app
purchases so that was the goal the
original stated goal and they were able
to successfully do that so let me go
through the story here so developer
invent venture integrated spend
prediction into their game galactic
empire it's a great game they use the
spend prediction to determine whether or
not to show AdMob rewarded ads and
here's how it works for them if a player
is predicted to spend they don't show
the rewarded ad option if a player is
predicted to spend to not spend sorry
they
we'll see rewarded ads and they
implemented this about a month ago and
in the short time since then they've
been able to increase ads revenue by 10%
without any negative effect impact on
in-app purchases in fact they've seen a
slight increase in them and it's a great
case study and every developer large or
small can go out today and combine the
player stats API and AdMob in this way
to improve the success of their game and
since we launched the player stats API
last year we've continued to invest in
new predictions to make the API even
more powerful and we're excited to
announce the launch of two new
predictions in the coming weeks the
first is a prediction of how much
someone is likely to spend in the next
28 days and the second is a prediction
of whether or not someone is likely to
become a high spender and we couldn't be
more excited to see what creative things
you'll end up doing with these new
predictions so let's turn our attention
to help to how Google and play can help
you harness the energy and creativity of
your gaming community to deepen player
engagement and so one thing that we've
recently launched is play games gamer
IDs and avatars and these are a great
way for your players to create their own
gaming persona and express themselves I
mean most of the people I know don't
really want to play games as the real
identity I don't want to be known as Ben
Frankel and all the potentially strange
games that I play and in fact I've used
the same ID my secret nerd name kaldorf
here which you can see on the screen and
since I created my battlenet account to
play Starcraft a really really long time
ago I was no longer Ben Frankel computer
science TA and college student I was the
Zerg slaying kaldorf the Conqueror right
and it was very satisfying to carry that
persona to all of my games going forward
and with gamer ID
which we launched earlier in the year I
can in fact take this persona with me to
every game I play it has developers you
can actually tap into this as well you
can find out what a gamer idea is when
somebody signs in so if you have a game
where you have your equivalent of a
gamer ID or a gamer tag you can pre
populate that field with the ID that
I've chosen and that should speed up the
flow of people into your game so now I
want to talk about how the video
recording API in YouTube can help
developers amplify their community's
impact so for a bit of background late
last year we made it possible for users
to record their gameplay with the Google
Play games app and after an extended
early access program today we are
excited to announce it in the coming
weeks the video recording API will be
available to all developers so that
players can bring up this video
recording experience directly from your
games in addition players will also soon
have the option to livestream their
gameplay to YouTube so we've seen a lot
of excitement for video recording from
the smallest developers all to the very
largest we have on the platform and more
than a dozen games during the EAP
program the early access program have
already launched an integration with the
video recording API and they're on the
store today so you can go check them out
but I wanted to walk you through one
particularly powerful exemplary
integration of the video recording API
and flare games has just such an
integration in their game dawn of Steel
and here's how it works
so before you launch or raid and invade
another base and blow things up you come
to the screen on your left so yeah there
we go okay
and on this screen you can see that red
button has launched written in the
middle of it you click that bun you
launch the raid and fun ensues just to
the left of that red button is a camera
icon and if you click that camera icon
it brings up the video recording overlay
and then from that overlay you have all
the controls you need to
mute your mic turn off and on the Ford
facing camera as well as of course start
and stop the video recording and once
the recording is complete you can edit
the video and upload it directly to
YouTube and you can see here on your
right in the screenshot here that I've
clipped this video a little bit in the
editing mode and you can also see that
we've hopefully pre-populated the title
as well as the description so that
players can share their replays faster
and in the words of flair games John
Howard the video recording API helped
activate our community by enabling
players to create a let's play style
video in a matter of minutes with
minimal effort and it's not just minimal
effort for the players it's actually a
very easy integration to do and many of
the developers we talked to said it's
taken about a day to do it so it's a big
ROI for you guys but what particularly
excited me was how dawn of Steel
incorporated the video recording API as
a foundational element of their global
replay competition and in the view of
the folks and flare games the replay
share function was the perfect tool to
kick off the global competition and let
the community show off their skills that
is exactly the intent behind the video
recording API and what we wanted
developers to do with it to create these
kind of amazing experiences where people
can show off their skills they also did
a really really good job of
incorporating YouTube celebrity platform
into their marketing campaign for the
competition and here's how it worked to
kick off the competition they worked
with YouTube celebrity master off to
create a video tutorial and how to use
the video recording feature it's a
really impressive video and I thought I
would take the opportunity to show to
you so q awesome video and audio
what's up everyone
master off here with an awesome
free-to-play mobile game dawn of Steel
with the games replay feature you can
save your battles and share them with
others to do so simply toggle the record
button and hit play before battle
commences when you've destroyed an enemy
base with your squad stop the recording
check out your raid and share your
videos with the world easy as that
makes me wanna record video replay right
now but I'll wait so it was a really
great video high production value and I
think very effective way of driving
awareness about the competition and to
further amplify this corresponding
marketing campaign they had master of
announced the competition on his master
of gaming channel which has millions of
subscribers and is a great way to drive
awareness about the game and to cap it
off when the competition ended master of
then announced the winner and showed the
winning replay on his channel this is
exactly the type of coordinated
marketing campaign supported by video
replays that every game developer should
aspire to and I was blown away when I
heard about what they were doing and
next cue next slide please
there we go so to recap play games whoa
okay
well now we're too far all right and we
also ruining the slides back no no no
wrong way wrong way wrong way I think
you want to go to slide 38 just uh or
slide 28 bear with us for a moment here
we're experiencing technical
difficulties
and you can also see all the things I'm
saying on there that's super helpful all
right so to recap play games and other
Google services can be combined in
powerful ways to help you find the right
users tailor and tune game experiences
to different player segments and harness
the energy and creativity of your gaming
community to deepen player engagement
and now I'll hand it off to ena you've
seen some sneak preview of her slides
already to talk about YouTube gaming and
the how the YouTube platform has been
used to drive developer success thank
you
hey my name is Xena and I work on the
YouTube gaming team as a partnerships
manager so that means I manage or look
after some of our top YouTube gaming
creators like master of and gaming
publishers across Europe and today I'm
here to tell you about the amazing
innovative creative and powerful
community that we have on YouTube gaming
and how you as a developer can play an
active part in it but to truly
understand the phenomenon of gaming on
YouTube I want to share a personal story
so spoiler this is me and my brother
when we were little kids and I guess the
socks in the sandals kind of showed that
I was born and raised in Germany though
thanks mom and dad
anyhow my older brother and I would
actually spend hours and hours of
playing Monkey Island together
which is why for me today it's even a
greater honor to be speaking here as
Noah is one of the co developers of my
childhood game so in YouTube terms I'm
fangirling a little bit here we'll take
a selfie later so back then it was
usually me watching my brother play and
you know I was throwing in Commons here
and there he wouldn't really pass on the
controller ever but also to me he was
just the greatest monkey island player
in the world and also the only one I
knew but I was just being greatly
entertained and you know I kept coming
back into his room to watch more and
more of his gameplay on the few games
that he had bought with his pocket money
so we were if you think about it our own
little gaming community even though
quite isolated now also on the game
development side the industry back then
was quite isolated so developers and
publishers often had no clue of what was
going to happen the day of the release
of their game
and players wouldn't really know what
they were going to see until they really
bought the game unless they had maybe
read something about it in a game
specific magazine or heard about it from
friends but that was pretty much it now
the future of gaming as I had imagined
and back then where I could just kind of
watch any game I could think of is
already happening today and funnily
enough I find myself working at the very
core of it with YouTube we are surfacing
all of these little gaming communities
and bring them together without
limitations so you see while it was
really great watching my brother play I
could have never imagined a world where
I could just choose between different
types of personalities to be entertained
by and seamlessly switch between games
and even get recommendations to discover
new games based on my preferences and
anyone can do all of that today on
YouTube YouTube has really reshaped the
video game landscape over the past
decade and to fully understand how it's
important to look at the incredible
amount of innovative and creative talent
that we have on the platform who are
often at the tip of the spear when it
comes to creating new formats inspiring
trends and establishing audience
building strategies creativity has gone
way beyond just gameplay so today on
YouTube you can find everything from the
most engaging and entertaining let's
play video to 360 degrees animations of
games to a cappella songs of your
favorite game soundtrack to animate it
serious to even baking videos of your
favorites game character as a muffin so
people find themselves more interested
and curious about gaming content than
ever before and the community is
constantly diversifying in which gamers
are not only players anymore
in every month people watch billions of
hours of gaming content on YouTube so
gaming on YouTube has grown so strongly
that last year in the summer we took a
step further and we launched YouTube
gaming providing a dedicated home for
users to get connected to the games
players and culture that made it matter
to them with videos live streams and
actually the biggest community of gamers
on the web all in one place so if you
haven't seen the YouTube gaming app I
highly encourage you to download it to
your phone or if you are on desktop you
can access by visiting gaming
youtube.com now gaming videos have
gained a lot of traction over the past
decade to the point where youtubers in
their videos are playing a crucial role
in the economics of the gaming industry
creators videos are one of the major
factors influencing which games get more
exposure and find success so we've seen
an incredible amount of movement on the
developer and publisher side one example
of this is surgeon simulator an indie
game by bus's studios now this is a
story from back in 2013 and a thumbnail
from a PewDiePie video PewDiePie is
actually our biggest youtuber on the
platform by subscribers he uploads
mostly gaming videos and to date his
channel has reached more than 44 million
subscribers and today he has reached
more than 12 billion views on his videos
so I reached out to Felix PewDiePie to
get approval to use this image in my
presentation and his only comment to it
was oh my god inna what an ancient image
so considering three years as ancient
you kind of get a sense of how fast the
industry is moving here surgeon
simulator is the game by Busta Studios
an indie game developer in London and so
back in 2013 they up
loaded this game to their game jams side
without really having any expectations
then Felix also known as PewDiePie found
the game loved it and he decided to make
a video about it shortly after he
uploaded the video the game gem site
crashed because there was an overload of
PewDiePie fans
accessing the side to download the game
and to make things worse yet other
youtubers followed and created videos
about surgeon simulator which kind of
really skyrocketed the game and to put
it in bosses Studios words the traction
in the first week was insane this
exposure and momentum has led to surgeon
simulator becoming the fastest ever
greenlit game on Steam and they now find
themselves with an established IP that
has sold over three million units across
five different platforms way to go for
an indie game in overtime Bossa studios
has become really involved with the
YouTube community to a point where in a
later version of their game the alien
version they named the organs after some
of their biggest YouTube supporters I
know that's very flattering but that's
kind of just the fun of YouTube another
great example of how they work with the
YouTube community is from their game I
am bread I am bread is a very fun action
adventure and simulation game where the
player is in control of a slice of bread
and the ultimate goal is to get the
bread toasted turns out there was a bug
in the game which made the bread float
around in zero gravity
and of course youtubers discovered that
bug and had a lot of fun with it the
YouTube community actually loved that
buck so much that there were hundreds of
videos produced around the floating
bread it really became a thing so
instead of fixing the bug Bossa studios
really heard the community they built
the zero
gravity modes into the game and released
it as a free update so today you can
find many many fun Let's Plays on
YouTube around the space bread so guess
what not only in the game developers are
working with the YouTube community GTA
is a very popular game on YouTube
youtubers just love recording their
gameplay and it's an amazing game to
develop storytelling so Rockstar the
publisher of GTA wanted to further fuel
that creativity and enable creators to
share more of their experiences in an
entirely new way so they integrated the
Rockstar editor into GTA 5 it's a
feature built within the game that lets
players record edit and ultimately share
highlight moments from their gameplay
using different camera angles filters
audio and so on
players can record gameplay footage with
only the press of a single button within
the game there's even a director mode
where you can stage your own scenes and
create custom moments players can choose
from different story mode characters
they can choose location time day and
even the weather when done editing they
can export directly to YouTube and we've
seen some amazing results coming through
we see more collaboration between
developers YouTube creators and the
community than ever before and it's very
exciting
going back to PewDiePie he recently had
really released his own game pewdiepie
legend of the brofist in conjunction
with outer minds a video game
development company now in the process
of developing the game he constantly
worked with his fans in his community
and got their input he shared sneak
peeks of levels and walkthroughs and
they could give their feedback through
YouTube comments they also had a say on
which other youtubers should be included
in the game as characters and the
community even voted on the
name of the game the feedback from the
community was so mind-blowing that the
game became number one in the App charts
right after launch but we also see
developers taking a stab at becoming
content craters themselves and quite
successfully so Miniclip for example has
done a tremendous job on their main
official channel agario they are not
only collaborating with youtubers and
curating community content they also
host regular live streams bringing in
the community manager and feature guests
players on the official channel so this
very inclusive and very consistent
content strategy has led to the Miniclip
agario channel reached over 1 million
subscribers within only 6 months of
launch which is quite impressive what's
great about producing your own official
content is that you can then link
directly from the YouTube watch page to
your game through what we call cards
cards are clickable from any device and
can either link to your official website
or in the case of a mobile game directly
to the Google Play Store and drive
downloads of the game additionally the
game pages on YouTube gaming
automatically pull together all the
great content that is being produced
around your game into one place so
that's actually a great place for you as
a developer to discover all the creative
talent out there that's already creating
videos and livestreams around your IP
and get in touch if you've released the
game I highly recommend you to check out
your own game page on YouTube gaming and
I've also included a link in ours into
our space for the session and Noah will
explain a little bit about what that is
again on how you can provide us with
information around your game for these
pages or you could just Google provide
YouTube with game data and you will find
that link
and speaking of more product innovations
let's talk mobile now we've looked at
mobile gaming and we just see
skyrocketing growth if looking at those
numbers it was very clear to us that we
not only wanted to make it an awesome
experience to watch people play from a
mobile phone but also to share your own
mobile gameplay and broadcast it to the
world now Ben has already told you about
the amazing stuff you can do around
integrations within your game but we
want to also be inclusive of any type of
game so part of our update to the
YouTube gaming app as well as to Google
Google Play games as Ben mentioned
earlier with mobile capture mobile
capture on YouTube gaming is drop-dead
simple you can select any game on your
phone
and just tap the record button and start
capturing you could just add video of
yourself sound via the mic and you know
adding to the fun of it you can
livestream all of that game play
directly to your channel on YouTube
already today so really your limits to
your mobile gameplay recording is only
your phone's battery now and speaking of
life streaming we're building up amazing
features on that front as I said earlier
we see constant innovation around
formats on YouTube and more and more
craters are now connecting to their fans
real time through life streaming also
developers and publishers often use live
streams to make announcements to host
tournaments to host community streams
around their launches and really engage
with their fans through life chat life
is becoming an ever immersive experience
and we even recently announced 360
degrees life streaming it's a very
exciting era to be in today and the
games industry and there's so many cool
products available to the people who
love and make games in the past 15
minutes or so I was only able to give
you kind of a glimpse into this world
and there's so many more inspirational
stories from games
that have become really big and known
through the power of the YouTube
community the discovery of games has
really changed and you don't need to
spend millions of dollars of marketing
budget anymore to get exposure so I
highly encourage you to play an active
role in our community by embracing the
content that's out there or creating
your own by really listening to the
community's feedback maybe even
including them in the development of
your game it all really boils down to
making great games and to the combined
passion that we share for games and with
that I want to hand back over to Noah
thank you Anna Thank You Ben and thank
you everyone I hope this has been
intriguing inspiring I hope you can see
some ways you can use these services in
your games please go out there and make
some great games with our technology and
let us know what you've done so we can
show you up here next year thank you
very much
you